del enfrentamiento entre Rusia y Ucrania
se ha trasladado aquí a la sede de
Naciones Unidas en Nueva York y todo ha
sido por un minuto de silencio durante
la celebración del Consejo de Seguridad
Nacional de Naciones Unidas el ministro
de exteriores ucraniano ha terminado su
discurso sorprendiendo a todos los
asistentes pidiendo pidiéndoles que se
levantaran y guardaran un minuto de
silencio por las víctimas Durante este
último año de guerra en Ucrania lo han
hecho y de repente el embajador ruso ha
empezado a golpear la mesa y a pedir a
la presidencia del consejo que en este
caso recae en Malta que le diera el
turno de voz cuando lo ha hecho ha dicho
que también se guardara Un minuto de
silencio que todo el mundo se pusiera en
pie por todas las víctimas que han
fallecido Durante los últimos años desde
el 2014 en ese momento se han vivido
unos minutos de confusión en los que los
asistentes muchos no sabían si
levantarse o sentarse Incluso el propio
secretario general de Naciones Unidas
Antonio Gutiérrez se iba a sentar de
repente se ha vuelto a levantar seguido
de algunos de los asistentes el
embajador ruso que es un zorro viejo en
esto de la diplomacia de Naciones Unidas
lleva ya muchos años ha conseguido
convertir la estrategia de Ucrania para
denunciar las víctimas de esta guerra en
una victoria propia